elektrisiert hat es ihn auf jeden Fall
das neue Angebot seine Stromanbieters
denn Michelle Böhne soll unglaublich
viel mehr für Strom zahlen statt wie
bisher 74.000 soll er
470.000 Euro im Jahr zahlen der
Einzelhändler aus Stadthagen bei
Hannover ist entsetzt
wir waren geschockt das war für uns
unvorstellbar dass wir dem Angebot
bekommen über das
sechseinhalbfache sollten wir ein Strom
bezahlen ab nächstes Jahr das können wir
gar nicht stemmen wir verteidigen hier
20 Arbeitsplätze das funktioniert
einfach so nicht
300.000 Kilowattstunden Strom verbraucht
der Supermarkt im Jahr Kühlung Technik
Licht das kostet reichlich Energie und
Geld
der Strom muss für uns bezahlbar sein
wir haben großartig keine Möglichkeit an
Energie zu sparen wir haben ein IT die
rund um die Uhr läuft wie am Kühlungen
die rund um die Uhr im Einsatz sind
dass da sind keine großartigen
Ansparungen möglich eigentlich müsste er
die Mehrkosten an die Kunden weitergeben
aber dann könnten auch weniger kommen
Kauf Zurückhaltung jetzt schon bei den
Verbrauchern
man ist überrascht man packt fünf Teile
in den Beutel und ist auf einmal bei 30
Euro an der Kasse wo man vorher bei der
Hälfte war ich gucke gezielter auf die
Preise schaue nach wochenangeboten und
tendenziell auch weniger im Moment
besorgt mich das noch nicht weil ich
noch mein Auskommen habe aber ich weiß
ja nicht was kommt
Besorgnis auch 300 Kilometer weiter
nördlich in Kiel wie viel der Kaufmann
martenfreund im nächsten Jahr für Strom
und Gas zahlen wird weiß er noch nicht
genau nur das ist deutlich mehr werden
wird
wenn ich überlege dass ich nächstes Jahr
irgendwie 300.000 Euro Strom zahlen muss
dann kommt noch mal Gehälter dazu mit
fünf sechs sieben Prozent nächstes Jahr
wieder Einzelhandel neu verhandelt und
wenn das so weitergeht dann steuern wir
auf dem Infarkt zu
explodierende Energiepreise und
gestiegene Kosten bei den Lieferanten
zusätzlich zu Corona es sind schwierige
Zeiten Matten Freund fordert daher ein
konsequentes Handeln von der Regierung
wir brauchen von der Politik
Planungssicherheit und das ist das
schnellste was jetzt kommen muss jetzt
beschäftigen sie sich mit Gas was ist
mit Strom das dauert alles viel zu lange
viel zu lange
Einzelhändler unter Strom existenzangs
macht sich breit Hilfe vom Staat sehen
Experten aber kritisch die generelle
Linie sollte jetzt sein dass die
Unternehmen die höheren Energiekosten
weiter wälzen bis zu den Verbrauchern
dort kann der Staat dann auch gezielt
helfen wir können jetzt nicht für alle
Branchen entsprechen entsprechend
entlastungspakete Schnüren das würde
viel zu teuer eine Teuerung von über 500
Prozent für Strom und Michelle Bühne er
kann die Summe nur ein Raten zahlen es
bleibt die finanzielle Belastung halt
nur gestreckt